So well we've just seen a fully populated data Hall
Which we've reached capacity within and we never take you to what we call phase two dateable 3
which is the most recent capacity that we brought to the market really to facilitate the large demand that we're seeing from the
researchers and the higher education institutions
It's kind of after and before isn't it ok assuming we can get in
So this building was built three years ago, and the building shell was built three years ago
It was designed from the ground up as a data center most data centers are converted
buildings of some description predominately where and distribution warehouses so a lot of thought went into just the simple building fabric to make it simpler
More cost-effective and easier to operate in life
Support stories where the fire suppression system
Resides so there's an if there's a fire within the building
the system in the each of the data pools can figure out exactly where that fire is and provide directly the
Fire suppression to it to make sure that we put the fire out
This is very responsible
So this is the second phase of capacity that we're bringing on live within the facility
It delivers two thousand five hundred kilowatts of IT load and what we've just shown you is a fully populated operational data
Hall with all the racks and the IT infrastructure running in anger within it
this is just about to have the first item of structure installed within it and
That will be going live in the next six to eight weeks
The space the power the connectivity
Yeah, yeah
So we are simply the facilitator of the building the infrastructure that supports it all the resilience that they require to make sure they're comfortable
They're there
I t's housing the right place in the right
Location that it's always on and we are the kind of the base layer for the foundation if you like of the IT stack in
That regard so how many customers?
In a date or this side
We would look to get between 20 and 30 higher education research customers within this sort of space of capacity
Doing there'll be a loss of high-performance computing in here
But we will see more and more standard applications and standard IC footprint coming within this space
yeah, where email web access and the way we put that into context is you'll have a
standard enterprise rack of computing wall really supported by four kilowatts of electricity a
High performance computing rack could be supported by up to 30 kilowatts of electricity
And that's the difference that's there they can be very different in the amount of variety hardware
That's within it, and is the power of the supporter in the past
These are institutions are trying to go and procure these services directly in the market themselves
in effect what's happened is janeth genic straight jessica brought them together and
consolidated their requirements
And we treat them as a single customer
even though there are many customers that sit underneath the JISC agenda framework and in doing so we can therefore offer a
Wholesale type price the pod that we were standing in previously would be costing them
Probably thirty thousand pounds a month or something like that depending upon the IT load within it if you look at the analysis that
Jessica and Jennifer done they reckon that they are the customers are saving up to two thirds of their cost
From trying to provision it themselves put it in within their own
Campus estates or trying to go to market directly without having the framework around them so the cost is cost savings are significant so
Obviously we're all now no no he's not here. How long before this is a heathen web computing
Well the space we were just in we filled within eight months and at the beginning of the framework
it's a wizard that the Quietus piece of time period of time if you like so I
will forecast this will be filled in the next six months and
Because of our confidence in that we've already started phase three which delivers a similar amount of capacity in space
That's just behind you
For your finger onto the finger vein reader
It's part of the cloud we're not the cloud
It's part of the cloud
And what are we are we don't have an ambition to be a cloud provider our ambition is simply to enable the cloud